[Music]
you know it's funny there's um there are
these constant friends reunion questions
that you get asked
all the time
and there was a
friends reunion hoax recently
it fooled a bunch of people yeah but
apparently it also fooled you yeah a
little bit yeah well what what how did
that happen okay first of all the
graphics for this one thing was
unbelievable they put out i think we
have a picture here they put this up and
this was
this was i guess on the web and uh you
know it was it was all around town and
people saw it and yeah it looked real it
looked really real and then they were
posting this article and the headline
was like nbc confirms five out of six of
the friends are in
and i went oh my god they didn't ask me
well that's enough five is plenty
and then i realized oh no nbc didn't own
the show right warner brothers did so it
took you a second
took me a second but i really i was hurt
be really
of course you'd be hurt it's just it's a
good thing you figured it out before you
called the other five and chewed them
out oh like yeah i could just see me how
come you said you would do it but i i
mean i don't even know where to begin
that's too humiliating
i know i know no one told me everyone
deliberately didn't tell me because they
knew i wasn't included you know it was
your mind starts to run away it happened
in
yes it was very brief with a lot of
thoughts do you get tired of do you get
tired of those questions though i mean
there's hope i mean people want it to
happen so badly that you feel like
enough already you know well i know you
know what honestly i don't feel enough
already i honestly just feel really bad
that you know just by saying and that
was actually never something that was
ever going to happen right you're
disappointing them and people got mad at
me recently because i had said no no i
mean that's never going to happen they
were angry like i'm the one who shut it
down by saying
right it's something that didn't exist
in the first place and then they get mad
at you for you stopped it the thing that
was never going to happen i stopped the
fantasy yes that it was going to happen
okay no you can still imagine that it
might happen
that's up to you
and gumdrops will fall from the skies
yes that happens you are
you just had a birthday and you but you
had no birthday party at least that's
what you told me
heard a lot of music coming from your
house
saw a long conga line coming out uh
no no yeah pony ride yeah andy came back
that was fun
yeah and he had fudge all around his
mouth that was fantastic
i got to keep one of the ponies
but you decided not to have a party why
did you not have a why did you decide
not to have a party it's funny that i
gave away ponies
it is funny it was a great party
um no i didn't have a party i didn't
really want to have a party because i
had thought actually at some point i was
going to do maybe i'll just have like a
big party and everyone i've ever met and
you know just wouldn't that be nice
but then i realized even like a hundred
people would be i mean if you make small
talk with you know you have to say hello
to everybody right and that's like three
to five minutes right times a hundred
yeah i mean that's forever yeah that's a
lot of
i mean you can't even get i mean then
you just like say hi oh it's good to see
you and you look great so i'm going to
turn the lights out now yeah you have to
leave you have to go after that oh my
god but you said have a party for
everyone you've ever met i wouldn't do
that no and i would have met a lot of
bad people in my life
i don't want to see everybody at my
birthday but you didn't have any small
party at all and you can tell me it's
all right that i didn't i really did
okay i really didn't can you still give
andy a pony
i really
that's good yes he does as if if he did
i would like shoot now i have to get
andy pony it's all
it's all he talks about in the
commercial breaks whenever we go to
commercial i want a pony